[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
on a un immeuble qui est en train de se
construire qui va accueillir à la fois
un restaurant universitaire et un
immeuble de bureaux et c'est un immeuble
qui est sous maîtrise d'ouvragé directe
de l'établissement public d'aménagement
paris saclay et dans lequel nous allons
expérimenter la collecte séparative des
urines ce projet né de la volonté de la
direction développement durable de paris
saclay notamment julie tissot
d'expérimenter ces collecte séparative
des urines et du coup ils ont fait appel
à évoluer
ma collègue louise ragués pour les aider
à implanter cette solution à dialoguer
avec les agriculteurs et à dialoguer
également avec des la chambre
d'agriculture plante et cité et l'inra
et pour voir comment faire une véritable
expérimentation scientifique donc les
enjeux de la collecte séparative des
urines c'est d'une part de soustraire
leur hymne des réseaux d'assainissement
puisque les urines contient 85 % de la
zone pour rejeter cet azote est lourd à
traiter pour les stations d'épuration et
se retrouve à la fin dans les rivières
et les cours d'eau et contribuer à ce
qu'on appelle l'eutrophisation des cours
d'eau c'est à dire que quand il ya trop
d'azoté sacré trop d'agde ça prend trop
d'oxygène et ça tue la faune aquatique
donc l'idée c'est de d'une part de
retirer la zone des stations d'épuration
et l'autre par c'est d'emmener cet azote
dans les champs notre approvisionnement
de l'engrais c'est à 90% de l'encré de
synthèse qui est produit à partir de
beaucoup d'énergie notamment de gaz
naturel et si jamais on peut récupérer 7
7 urine pour fertiliser les champs et
ben on évite de produire et d'apporter
cet engrais alors concrètement à quoi ça
consiste dans le bâtiment ça consiste à
mettre des urinoirs sans eau pour ne pas
avoir lu rinne qui est diluée par les
chasses d'eau et ensuite ça consiste à
mettre un réseau séparé dans le bâtiment
pour ramener tous aturine jusqu'à une
cuve qui va centraliser et la stocker
pour le bâtiment juste avant d'arriver
dans cette cuve on installe un filtre à
charbon actif qui permet
d'éliminer tous les polluants
pharmaceutique potentiel et 7 urines
elle est stockée et elle est prélevée
une à deux fois par an par un
agriculteur qui va après les pendre sur
le plateau de saclay
concrètement sur cet immeuble on pense
on estime qu'on récoltera à peu près 20
mètres cubes d'urines parents et ses 20
mètres cubes pourront fertiliser un
hectare et demi de blé une fois que
cette expérimentation sera lancée ne
pourra étudier l'opportunité de
généraliser cette collecte et du coup de
fertiliser une part significative
des champs de paris saclay tout en
préservant les rivières alentour